Speaker 1: Real quick, in one of the absolutely
wildest unhinged rants of the Mike Pillow era.
He went on TV. After a brief hiatus, his
own show. I think it's important to say.
Speaker 2: We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Yeah, not that. But he now is claiming
to have people and cameras watching polling places
in every county, as well as so-called cyber guys
that can look inside voting machines in real time.
If he's lying, then he's very
ill. If he's telling the truth,
these are probably crimes. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: This election and I'm telling
everyone out there, we are watching from every
angle where there's people in every state,
every county, every precinct. BRANNON Remember,
they may think you can't look and see what's going
inside that black box, but we can know in real
time through something called the Edison Report,
why we have cyber guys watching this. We I looked
at a thing today. It was on my my Twitter back
from November of 2020. And they showed CNN 20,000
votes dropping right off of Donald Trump's total
in real time. You guys, votes don't go in reverse.
These are computer manipulation algorithms.
So what I'm telling you is this election, it's
all eyes. We have all the camera angles. Now,
why? Even now, everyone would say, Well, Mike,
why are you telling the bad guys right now?
Well, I'm telling them they.
Speaker 1: Are the bad guys.
Speaker 2: Because the way I look at it, we're
going to it's going to be a win win because
the ones where we can override the algorithms
are going to be there. They're going to win.
And then I'll show the ones they don't. All
of it. Yeah, we got it all under camera. Well,
maybe this time around, the judges and the
left with the left media and maybe even the
right media. Fox News and Newsmax will actually
report if there's machines that are involved
in this election to steal another election.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, I don't know whether
he thinks he's telling the truth or whether he's
delusional or whether it is the truth and he's
admitting to crimes. I don't know about any of it,
but we need to get beyond this type of thinking.
For every pillow man, there are 10,000, 50,000,
250,000 people who literally believe this stuff.
Is it a million? I don't know. It is a sickness.
It is a sickness. And for everybody who's been
asking me, hey, you know, David, Mike Pillow,
when you interviewed him a couple of weeks ago,
he said he was going to send you some free pillows
for you to try them. Did he ever do it? No,
we did not. So that also by by the way,
I'm very happy with the pillows I have,
but I would have been curious to try the
mike pillows. He also did not do that.